étant arrivé monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues avec le président de la
commission des affaires européennes
Jean-François Rapin nous avons souhaité
prolonger nos échanges du 23 mars
dernier consacré à la presse par une
nouvelle matinée centrée cette fois sur
l'audiovisuel cette table ronde sur les
enjeux de la liberté des médias
audiovisuels en Europe vient
utilement prolonger le débat de la
semaine dernière au Sénat sur l'avenir
d'audiovisuel public et les médias
privés organisés à l'occasion d'examen
en sciences publiques de la proposition
de loi dont j'avais pris l'initiative
l'acte européen sur la liberté des
médias vise à garantir les des médias
libres et assurer leur pluralité il
trouve son origine dans certaines
dérives intervenues dans plusieurs pays
d'Europe orientale mais il fait
également écho à des problématiques que
connaissent les pays d'Europe de l'Ouest
dans lesquels les médias sont confrontés
à une crise sérieuse de leur modèle
permettez-moi rappeler rapidement les
contours le développement de la
publicité sur les réseaux sociaux et les
plateformes de vidéos entraînent la
baisse des ressources des médias
oudiovisuels traditionnels et
fragilisent leur investissement dans
deux secteurs que l'on sait justement
coûteux l'information et le sport
deuxième phénomène l'émergence des
grandes plateformes internationales de
vidéos par abonnement renchérit le coût
des programmes pour les chaînes
historiques lorsqu'elles ne les prient
pas tout simplement de ces programmes
qui sont diffusés en exclusivité sur les
plateformes et enfin non troisième
facteur le développement des télévisions
connectées créent un risque de
relégation pour les médias traditionnels
dans des sous menus difficilement
accessibles pour les utilisateurs faute
de visibilité appropriées sur les
télécommandes et les interfaces
utilisateurs des téléviseurs un risque
similaire existe pour les radios avec le
développement de l'IP qui privilégie
les plateformes de musique et de
podcasts enfin l'audiovisuel public est
fragilisé par la remise en cause de son
financement dans plusieurs pays
européens par les difficultés qui
rencontrent pour innover et s'adresser à
des jeunes publics et par la nécessité
de sélectionner des dirigeants
compétents pour conduire des
transformations nécessaires ce qui peut
être contradictoire avec un processus de
nomination publique menée par le
régulateur les médias européens sont
donc confrontés à des injonctions
contradictoires on leur demande de
respecter le pluralisme un moment où
leur poids relatif diminue et où les
investissements nécessaires appellent
plutôt à la concentration la
réglementation qui leur est imposée et
continue à contraindre leur
développement alors que dans le même
temps la réglementation imposée aux
plateformes définies au niveau européen
demeurent beaucoup plus souple enfin le
maintien d'un volume important de
publicité sur le service public réduit
la spécificité de son offre qui doit
également composer avec des impératifs
d'audience et la nécessité de ne pas
déplaire aux annonceurs
qui fragilise aussi son indépendance et
sa spécificité au final il ne faudrait
pas que les plateformes et les réseaux
sociaux continuent à bénéficier d'une
grande liberté d'action tandis que on
continuerait à accroître les contraintes
sur les médias traditionnels avec le
risque de fragiliser leur existence même
la question essentielle posée par ce
projet de règlement et de savoir s'il
peut être adopté mise en œuvre en
l'absence de disposition permettant tout
à la fois de réduire les asymétries avec
les plateformes de supprimer certaines
contraintes en matière de concentration
qui dissuade les nouveaux investisseurs
de participer au développement de ces
médias et de clarifier l'émission
l'organisation et le financement du
service public notre table ronde du jour
doit ainsi nous permettre grâce aux
interventions du Président de la
comroc-olivier Mestre et de la
directrice générale des médias et
industries culturels Madame Florence
Philbert de prendre la mesure des
objectifs du nouveau règlement européen
sur la liberté des médias sur
rendez-vous est également l'occasion
d'identifier grâce aux interventions des
représentants des médias publics et
privés représentés par Monsieur
Christophe Tardieu secrétaire général de
France Télévisions et de Madame Marie
gros Chevallereau de M6 leurs attentes
pour préserver leur attractivité dans un
secteur de plus en plus réglementé je
laisse à présent la parole au président
Jean-François Rapin président de la
commission des affaires européennes
afin qu'ils nous présentent les autres
intervenants du jour donc sans avoir
remercié chacun d'entre vous d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
merci merci monsieur le Président cher
Laurent d'abord excusez-moi de mon petit
retard mais j'avais rendez-vous avec le
secrétaire général aux Affaires
européennes et on a tellement de sujets
abordés que 1h c'est trop court donc
monsieur le Président chers Laurent
Mesdames et Messieurs
mes chers collègues la commission des
affaires européennes que j'ai l'honneur
de présider à désigné trois rapporteurs
Florence blatrix compta André catholin
et Catherine Morin de saillie sur le
règlement proposé par la Commission
européenne pour créer un cadre
législatif européen commun sur la
liberté des médias l'objectif de départ
de ce texte est tout à fait louable
garantir l'indépendance des médias
notamment contrôlant les concentrations
le texte institut à cette fin un comité
de régulation européen chargé de
préserver le pluralisme du paysage
médiatique européen ce qui
représenterait une innovation importante
par rapport à notre propre système
national de régulation des médias
structuré de longue date comme vient de
le rappeler Laurent Lafont lors d'une
première table ronde au printemps nous
avons avons pu échanger avec les
représentants de la presse écrite sur
les préoccupations spécifiques à ce
secteur Régie notamment par la grande
loi de 1881 cette audition collective a
fait ressortir l'importance de la
régulation des plateformes et de la
protection des journalistes pour
défendre la liberté de la presse en
Europe
permettez-moi de rappeler qu'auparavant
la commission des affaires européennes
du Sénat avait contrôlé la conformité de
cette proposition législative européenne
aux principes de subsidiarité à
l'unanimité notre commission à juger
qu'avec cette proposition législative la
Commission européenne elle est trop loin
et ne respectait pas les compétences des
États membres nous avons donc proposé au
Sénat un avis motivé pour dénoncer ce
non respect du principe de subsidiarité
sous la forme d'une résolution que le
Sénat a définitivement adopté le 11
décembre dernier
n'était nullement en cause les
intentions les objectifs ou le font même
du texte mais sa valeur ajoutée par
rapport à un cadre législatif national
déjà très développé en France et sa base
juridique la Commission européenne
fondant son initiative sur le seul
article 114 du traité sur le
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne
destiné à assurer le fonctionnement du
marché intérieur le service juridique du
Conseil de l'Union européenne à
plusieurs semaines plus tard rendu un
avis qui fait écho à la résolution du
Sénat en estimant cette base diurétique
conforme mais en la nuançant quelque peu
pour certaines parties du texte en effet
s'il existe un marché intérieur des
médias en Europe celui-ci n'échappe pas
à une segmentation nationale culturelle
et linguistique qui justifierait
d'invoquer également l'article 17 du
même traité lequel appelle au respect de
la diversité culturelle et des
législations nationales
cela méritait d'être souligné à présent
nous sommes conscients de l'évolution du
texte au sein du calendrier
institutionnel de l'Union européenne le
groupe de travail audiovisuel du Conseil
a beaucoup avancé sur la présidente
suédoise qui s'achève bientôt et un
accord a été trouvé hier au corps sur un
texte dont nous espérons qu'il tient
notamment compte des observations que
nous avions formulées c'est donc sous
président espagnol que les trilogues
s'engageront le Parlement européen
devante examiner le texte en plénière en
octobre notre table ronde aujourd'hui
doit examiner les enjeux de ce règlement
européen sur un secteur des médias
audiovisuels en mutation rapide à
l'intérieur comme au-delà de nos
frontières je remercie très vivement
chacun d'entre vous d'avoir accepté d'y
participer nous sommes dans la
commission des affaires européennes très
attachées au dialogue des parlements
nationaux avec les institutions
européennes et notamment avec la
Commission européenne qui a évidemment
un rôle éminent d'initiative
législatives et dont émane le texte que
nous évoquons aujourd'hui
c'est pourquoi je suis heureux
d'accueillir monsieur Giuseppe à
basmonte directeur pour les médias au
sein de la Direction générale des
réseaux de communication du contenu et
des technologies la DG Connect direction
qui sous l'autorité du commissaire du
marché intérieur Thierry Breton et labor
et met en œuvre les politiques visant à
adapter l'Europe à l'ère numérique la
commission des affaires européennes est
également très engagée dans le dialogue
inter-parlementaire particulièrement
avec le Parlement européen en
l'occurrence dans son rôle de
collégisateur avec le conseil sur ce
texte c'est pourquoi je suis très
heureux d'accueillir en visioconférence
le député européen Geoffroy Didier qui
est le rapporteur de ce texte pour la
Commission du marché intérieur du
Parlement européen pour suivre la
logique chronologique du parcours
institutionnel européen je propose
Monsieur le Directeur de vous donner la
parole pour nous rappeler brièvement en
une dizaine de minutes si possible les
objectifs de ce texte en matière
audiovisuelle et son parcours actuel
puis cherche Geoffroy Didier en visio je
vous proposerai de prendre ensuite la
parole tout aussi brièvement pour nous
présenter une synthèse de votre rapport
et votre vision au titre de la
Commission du marché intérieur du
Parlement européen mais aussi si vous le
souhaitez en tant que député européen
français et Laurent l'a fait a présenté
les invités
qu'il avait souhaité voir autour de
cette table ronde
une semaine après l'adoption par le
Sénat de la proposition de loi
emblématique qu'il apportait avec Jean
Raymond Hugonnet sur le service public
lequel fait l'objet d'une législation et
d'une réglementation française très
exhaustive mais aussi d'un article de
cette proposition de règlement l'article
c'est le directeur c'est à vous
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président et
merci pour l'invitation et bonjour à
tout le monde
donc avec la proposition sous la liberté
des médias nous visons à promouvoir un
secteur des médias forts et indépendants
cet objectif répond à la nécessité pour
les médias des pouvoirs se développer
au-delà des frontières nationales et
d'être équipé pour faire face à la
concurrence accrue des gens en ligne
souvent pas européen
les entreprises des médias ne sont pas
un acteur parmi d'autres les médias
jouent un rôle essentiel dans notre
société et représente un pilier de
l'état des droits
et c'est pour cela que nous avons
proposé donc un instrument spécifique
marché intérieur basé sur l'article 114
du traité et l'objectif de la
proposition c'est par les biais de
l'harmonisation des supers de surmonter
toute une série d'entraves auxquelles
sont confrontés les entreprises des
médias européens contribuer aux
complètement du marché intérieur des
médias et en faisant cela
renforcer les l'indépendance et les
pluralismes des médias qui sont comme je
disais avant des éléments importants de
l'état des droits l'état des droits
comme là aussi qualifier la Cour de
justice n'est pas seulement important
pour les droits fondamentaux de citoyens
mais il est important ce fondamentale
pour les fonctionnements du marché c'est
impossible de innover c'est impossible
d'en te prendre s'il n'y a pas certitude
juridique que ce n'est pas le certitudes
juridiques et c'est tous les médias les
médias ne sont pas indépendants
donc la table ronde porte aujourd'hui
sous les enjeux du texte pour les médias
audiovisuels en cessant les dispositions
de la proposition relative à la
sauvegarde des indépendance des
journalistes ainsi que des médias privés
et publics qui est au centre de la
proposition auront un impact positif sur
l'indépendance et la liberté des médias
ces dispositions envisage entre autres
des gananteries des garanties contre
l'ingérence politique de la décision
éditoriale et contre la surveillance des
journalistes
la proposition comprend également des
mesures sur la transparence de la
propriété des médias et sur
l'attribution de la publicité étatique
et ces mesures devraient aider un
meilleur fonctionnement du marché
intérieur
des distorsions de la concurrence dans
les marchés et un éclairant les citoyens
et les acteurs du marché sous ces
questions clés
quand vous le savez les États membres
devront également examiner l'impact des
concentrations dans les secteurs des
médias sous la liberté et les
pluralismes des médias je crois que
c'est si tel système d'examen existent
déjà en France existe aussi en Italie
mais ce n'est pas le cas dans d'autres
États membres
je voudrais également souligner que la
proposition des règlements apporte des
réponses à un certain nombre de défis
auxquels sont confrontés les médias
européens qui découlent des
développements comme vous l'avez dit
avant numérique et des réalités
politiques en particulier nous avons
proposé des gardes fous pour renforcer
la position des médias vis-à-vis des
très grandes plateformes digitales en
ligne qui sont des passerelles d'accès
au contenu médiatique tout cela sera
fait de manière à compléter les règles
existantes en place telles que le
règlement digital
l'idée est également de renforcer la
coopération entre l'égulateur des médias
nationaux qui de par leur expertise ont
un rôle clé à jouer dans la recherche
des solutions aux défis communs en
particulier ce résultat
et la nécessité d'une coopération accrue
parmi les régulateurs c'est
démontré nécessaire pendant la guerre
pendant les conflits
afin de empêcher aux instruments des
propagande médiatiques russes de pouvoir
diffuser leur programme surtout dans
certains pays dans les pays baltiques et
en Pologne
donc comme vous l'avez dit les
colonisateurs se sont penchés activement
sur notre proposition depuis son
adoption ont ajouté la question de la de
la sociabilité de la majoridique était
discutée les textes a été à aménager et
sous-précidence suédoise les concerts
analysés en détail l'ensemble des
dispositions et s'est mis d'accord sur
une position commune hier permettant de
débuter les négociations avec les
parlements européens une fois que
celui-ci
aura également voté sur ces textes en
octobre merci
merci peut-être Geoffroy Didier donc si
on a la visio
je pense qu'il est
normalement il était connecté
on n'arrive pas
vas-y
merci monsieur le président madame
messieurs
c'est bien évidemment un texte très très
important qui arrive
au terme du mandat de l'actuel
commission il faut d'ailleurs saluer
l'activité de la commission pour nos
secteurs depuis le début de son mandat
si je le mets en perspective avec
l'adoption la directive service média
audiovisuel apporter beaucoup de
transformation
droit d'auteur DMA DSA avec la
régulation des plateformes en ligne et
maintenant l'aime fort cette un bilan
qui sera impressionnant pour notre
continent
j'exposerai rapidement les points de
vigilance que ce texte s'appelle de
notre de notre part et quand je dis
notre part de les regards du groupe des
régulateurs européens puisque l'arcom
joue sur les sujets institutionnels sur
les textes qui sont élaborés au niveau
de l'Union et au sein de la gare un rôle
un rôle central
pour dire d'abord que globalement
l'accueil à la gare de ce texte est un
accueil favorable et positif par une
naturelle comme la très bien rappelée
le directeur que que l'Union porte ses
valeurs c'est valeurs de démocratie de
valeur de liberté pour assurer une
protection des médias et donc de se
doter d'un corpus juridique minimum
commun au regard d'une situation qu'on
observe au sein de l'Union très
disparate pour ne pas dire très inégale
entre un pays comme la France qui a une
réglementation très sophistiquée entre
la loi de 1881 sur la liberté presse ou
la loi de 1899 de 1986 sur la liberté de
communication dans le champ dans le
champ audiovisuel avec des règles sur la
protection de la concentration on en a
souvent parlé avec vous monsieur le
Président Lafont lors de la commission
d'enquête du Sénat qui sont qui sont
très élaborés et d'autres pays on sait
que cette situation
n'est pas n'est pas identique
les points d'attention de l'erga et de
nous-mêmes vous les connaissez il y en a
un d'abord très important facteur commun
qui attrait à la à la presse écrite
dans la mesure où tous les régulateurs
que nous sommes l'arcome en particulier
n'exerce aucune mission de régulation à
l'égard de la presse de la presse écrite
donc c'est un point
d'attention que la regarde a toujours
souligné depuis le début avec beaucoup
de beaucoup de clarté
que la gouvernance de la même forme donc
le bord qui assurera la gouvernance de
ce de ce texte
pas plus que les autorités de régulation
nationale n'est vocation assurer une
forme de régulation de la presse la
presse écrite ça nous paraît un point de
vigilance très important la Commission a
eu l'occasion de dire que ce n'était pas
son son intention on s'en réjouit en
tout cas les regards exprimés très
explicitement son point d'attention
centrale sur cette question
le deuxième point d'attention monsieur
va monter ne sera pas surpris que je
l'évoque c'est l'indépendance effective
du bord à partir du moment où on
intervient dans le champ d'une liberté
publique fondamentale
la liberté de communication la liberté
des médias que la structure de
gouvernance du règlement le bord est
composé
d'autorité nationale indépendante
à l'image de l'arcom il nous paraît
naturel que le bord de lui-même et
toutes les caractéristiques de
l'indépendance
et ça ne serait pas pleinement le cas
notre sens si le secrétariat du bord est
assuré
comme cette encore le cas dans la
proposition de la Commission par par
l'exécutif européen c'est pas de
méfiance de la Commission européenne en
tant que telle mais il y a là une
question de principe
qu'une structure composée d'entités
elles-mêmes indépendante soit elle-même
pleinement indépendante pour porter sa
mission dans un champ une fois encore un
champ très sensible celui de d'une
liberté publique essentielle
autre point de vigilance
à nos yeux c'est la façon dont vis-à-vis
des plateformes de partage de contenu
sont traités les contenus en provenance
des médias des contenus et les contenus
médiatiques
la proposition de la Commission sur ce
point-là
va à notre sens dans la bonne direction
et c'est d'ailleurs je crois une avancée
par rapport au DSA aucune disposition de
traité de cette question
mais il nous semble qu'il faut être très
attentif à ce que le pouvoir
discrétionnaire des plateformes à
l'égard de contenu en provenance des
médias
le pouvoir d'élimination éventuelle de
tel ou tel contenu soit soit minimisé ou
en tout cas encadré pour éviter pour
éviter des excès
l'argat proposé de ce point de vue là
donc que le fournisseur de ce contenu
pouvons éventuellement poser question
disposent à minima d'un délai de réponse
à l'égard de la plateforme d'au moins 24
heures avant d'être de pouvoir être
suspendu par par la plateforme elle-même
donc c'est pour minimiser les risques à
l'égard des contenus en provenance en
provenance de médias je pense qu'il faut
faire attention sur ce point
et puis troisième point d'attention pour
nous fort de l'expérience vécue depuis
le début du conflit ukrainien c'est la
façon dont on
assure le traitement
du contrôle des chaînes qui sont
sous contrôle d'état des tatiales sous
influence si je puis dire là encore
la proposition de la Commission nous
paraît procéder d'une bonne d'une bonne
intention
la regarde s'interroge quand même pour
savoir si à ce stade encore suffisamment
précises
et les regards formulée une série de
propositions
pour qu'on ait une vraie coopération
entre entre les régulateurs nationaux
une vraie capacité du bord d'un pouvoir
se saisir
des situations problématiques pour
pouvoir formuler un avis éclairé sur la
position adoptée à l'égard de chaîne je
pense notamment de chaîne étrangères
diffusées par satellite qui soulèvera
une difficulté au regard des valeurs que
nous avons en partage sur notre sur
notre continent une fois encore c'est
tout ça est un peu lié à l'expérience
que nous avons vécu depuis le début du
conflit à la suite des différents
blocages
décidés par la Commission
voilà le dernier point de vigilance qui
a été évoqué à plusieurs reprises pour
nous c'est la bonne articulation de ce
texte avec les autres textes européens
je pense en particulier à la directive
service media audiovisuel pour tous ceux
qui touchent à la protection de la
création on a un corpus qui aujourd'hui
je crois c'est largement consensus donc
d'être toujours attentif aux effets de
friction possible d'un texte avec avec
l'autre plusieurs acteurs de la sphère
culturelle ont exprimé leur
préoccupations sur ce point-là et c'est
donc pour les regards naturellement un
point un point d'attention plus
particulier voilà j'ai essayé de tenir
dans les cinq minutes monsieur le
Président merci merci de votre concision
et de votre précision je crois que ça y
est la connexion est reprise avec
Geoffroy Didier Houston vous nous
entendez
bonjour Geoffroy coup de vas-y on
t'entend en tout cas voilà
j'espère que vous m'entendez bien et
pardonnez-moi effectivement de ce petit
problème technique je suis très heureux
de vous retrouver et vous remercie
évidemment d'avoir pris l'initiative de
cette réflexion commune
je vais essayer d'être synthétique nous
le savons tous ces 20 dernières années
le paysage numérique et audiovisuel a
subi de grands bouleversements
et les intermédiaires en ligne sont
devenus les champions de la
transformation numérique en s'imposant
sur le marché audiovisuel
ces plateformes en ligne
occupent une place essentielle dans
notre quotidien alors souvent pour le en
terme de liberté d'expression de partage
d'informations mais aussi nous le savons
pour le pire
lorsqu'on songe à la désinformation à la
dissémination de contenu haineux ou
d'images pornographiques à destination
des mineurs et le problème c'est que
nous avions un cadre légal qui était
pendant de longues années très peu
contraignants et qui leur laissait le
pouvoir de se réguler eux-mêmes et qui
provoquait des asymétries d'obligations
avec les médias traditionnels
ce qui posait évidemment un problème
majeur alors la législation
a commencé à se perfectionner fort
heureusement le Parlement européen et le
Conseil ont adopté en 2018 la directive
sur le service de média audiovisuel
nous avons ensuite pu mettre en place le
DSA et le DMA c'est-à-dire le digital
services actes le DSA et le dit le
Market actes DMA et nous sommes
effectivement en train en ce moment de
légiférer sur le média freedomacle alors
d'abord pourquoi un texte de plus
il y a un texte de plus aujourd'hui
parce qu'il a été considéré que vu la
situation de certains États membres il
était devenu important de l'éliférer au
niveau européen pour préserver
l'indépendance des journalistes pour
préserver la liberté des médias
mais aussi pour limiter les risques
d'interférence privée et publique sur la
liberté éditoriale et j'insiste en
disant que cet objectif il est louable
et qu'il mérite évidemment d'être
soutenu première chose deuxième chose
sur quelle base légale la Commission
européenne a-t-elle décidé de travailler
il s'agit là de l'article 114 du TFUE le
traité sur le fonctionnement de l'Union
européenne qui a été bien par la
commission et le présente propose donc
d'établir un ensemble commun de règles
applicables dans ce qui est appelé je
cite le marché intérieur des services de
médias
alors la commission proposiez un
règlement il faut être bien conscient
qui impliquerait des modifications de
droit nationaux lesquels sont pourtant
parfois anciens
apprécié efficace et
adapter aux spécificités locales et
culturelles ces droits nationaux ont
quand même souvent fait preuve de leur
efficacité dans la régulation des
secteurs concernés
ce que je veux vous dire c'est que
certes nous devons tous saluer
l'objectif louable de ce projet de
règlement
qui nécessite une harmonisation
européenne mais je voudrais aussi
souligner avec la même force
que qu'il existe dans le secteur des
médias plus particulièrement une
segmentation qui est principalement
nationale ou qui peut d'ailleurs être
régional dans les états fédéraux et qui
repose sur des fondements linguistiques
culturels qui sont souvent anciens et
pertinents
et ce que ce que je ne voudrais pas
c'est que nous remettions en cause les
systèmes nationaux qui fonctionnent
malgré la nécessité d'une législation
européenne pour modifier les dérives qui
existent dans certains États membres et
donc mon rôle de rapporteur c'est
précisément de trouver le juste
équilibre ce savon dosage qui existe
entre et qui doit exister entre la
nécessité d'une harmonisation européenne
pour préserver nos droits fondamentaux
et nos valeurs essentielles et ça c'est
évidemment majeur mais aussi pour
mais aussi une prise en compte des
législations nationale qui fonctionne
des modèles nationaux qui fonctionnent
et qui doivent être aussi préservés avec
la même force
avant de vous laisser la parole ce que
je voudrais vous dire et après vous
avoir
synthétiser l'état d'esprit dans lequel
je dirige mes travaux au sein de la
Commission du marché intérieur je
voudrais juste ajouter
les trois priorités qui me guident dans
mon travail plus technique d'abord une
prise en compte des spécificités locales
et des systèmes juridiques des États
membres qui existent par exemple de
clarifier les responsabilités en
créditeurs et rédacteurs afin de mieux
réfléchir de mieux refléter les
spécificités de certains États membres
ce qui existe aussi de limiter la
possibilité
offerte par la Commission européenne
dans sa proposition de règlement de
remettre en cause les mesures de
politique culturelle des États membres
ou les murs de transposition de la
directive et sa mort qui sont prises
notamment favorent la création je pense
évidemment au quotas de diffusion et
production d’œuvres d'origine européenne
aux attributions de licence à la
chronologie des médias ou aux aides
d'État tout ça ne doit pas être remis
sans cause première priorité donc mieux
prendre en compte les spécificités
locales et préserver les systèmes
juridiques des États membres lorsque ça
fonctionne deuxième priorité mais les
recoller mettre en a parlé renforcé
l'indépendance des autorités de
régulation et ça je crois que c'est
essentiel aussi de conférer le maximum
d'indépendance au Comité européen pour
les services de médias donc le board
nouvellement institué ainsi qu'aux
autorités nationales de régulation qui
doivent être indépendantes vis-à-vis de
la Commission et enfin dernière priorité
mais qui est tout aussi essentielle
mieux intégrer les plateformes en ligne
et les nouveaux outils numériques dans
le champ d'application du texte au
regard de la place prépondérante qu'ils
occupent dans le marché des médias
audiovisuels comme je l'ai dit il y a
quelques instants et cela nécessite par
exemple une obligation de mise en avant
des contenus d'intérêt général sur les
plateformes je crois que ça c'est
essentiel que
nous mettion cela en place cela exige le
droit par exemple de personnaliser
l'offre de services de médias pour le
consommateur sur son interface
utilisateur sur sa télécommande
aujourd'hui vous avez des télécommandes
avec un bouton d'une entreprise que je
ne citerai pas mais qui vous incite
directement à aller voir le programme de
cette plateforme alors que si vous
voulez retrouver sur votre Smart TV des
contenus des contenus d'information
général ça devient un véritable gymk ce
qui pose un vrai problème de principe et
enfin cette dernière priorité qui
consiste à mieux intégrer les
plateformes en ligne dans le champ
d'application du texte exige aussi des
obligations plus claires concernant la
gestion et la modération du contenu
fournie par les services de médias sur
les très grandes plateformes en ligne et
les moteurs de recherche pour éviter ce
qui se passe de plus en plus c'est à
dire des suppressions
ARB père et que j'estime abusive de
contenu par certaines plateformes qui se
réfugient derrière leurs conditions
générales d'utilisation pour imposer
leur idéologie ou en tout cas
leur politique de conditions générales
d'utilisation qui a parfois mettre en
exergue ou parfois suspendre voire
supprimer de manière totalement
arbitraire des contenus d'informations
générales
issue de médias reconnus comme tel donc
on voit bien aujourd'hui que nous sommes
à une période ils sont conclurai par là
charnière
décisive vitale pour les médias
notamment de services publics mais pas
seulement qui doivent
résister et combattre face à l'âme
submersion des plateformes numériques je
n'ai absolument rien contre les
plateformes numériques bien évidemment
et nous en utilisons tous dans nos vies
quotidiennes mais encore faut-il une
concurrence loyale et pour cela une
régulation à l'échelle européenne je
vous remercie
Florence Philbert directrice générale
des médias des industries culturels
merci à Monsieur les présidents mesdames
et messieurs et sénateurs durant
vous m'entendez merci à vous donc durant
sa présidence du Conseil de l'Union au
1er semestre 2022 la France avait fait
de la question de la liberté des médias
et de la protection du des journalistes
une priorité donc c'est nous
naturellement que les autorités
françaises ont soutenu des la
publication du texte en septembre 2022
les objectifs de cette initiative pour
restaurer la confiance des citoyens dans
les médias et renforcer leur
indépendance et leur pluralisme
donc la démarche des autorités
françaises a donc été naturellement
d'adopter une position constructive et
le ministère de la culture c'est attaché
à être force de proposition pour aider
au mieux la présidence du Conseil et la
Commission à trouver un compromis
l'enjeu est double donc cela a été dit
il s'agit de trouver un équilibre entre
d'une part l'objectif de permettre aux
médias d'exercer leur prérogative en
toute indépendance dans l'ensemble de
l'Union et d'autre part la nécessité
bien sûr de préserver les systèmes
nationaux donc parfois anciens parfois
complexe mais qui présente des garanties
incontestables s'agissant de
l'indépendance et du pluralisme des
médias
donc le mystère de la Culture a été
amené à travailler sur cette proposition
de règlement dans le cadre des
négociations entre États membres au sein
du Conseil de l'Union européenne ces
travaux ont débuté en septembre 2022
sous présidente tchèque avec six groupes
de travail qui ont été consacrés à
l'examen de ce texte et ces travaux se
sont poursuivis sous président suédoise
depuis janvier à un rythme assez soutenu
puisque 11 groupes de travail ont été
programmés donc les discussions ont été
intenses
ces efforts ont je crois payé puisque la
présidence suédoise a obtenu hier un
mandat de négociation du conseil lors du
comité des représentants permanents et
donc l'objectif est désormais que ce
texte puisse aboutir avant les élections
européennes de juin 2024
en termes de méthode la direction
générale des médias et des industries
culturelles pour cette discussion et ses
travaux c'est appuyé sur une
consultation des professionnels
consultation des professionnels des
différents secteurs concernés à la fois
le visuel la presse les plateformes pour
construire la position qui a été la
nôtre et cette consultation s'est
déroulée en février et en mars 2023 donc
cet exercice a permis de mettre en
évidence les principaux points
d'attention de ces secteurs que
évidemment nous avons essayé de prendre
en compte dans les discussions et
notamment pour n'en citer qu'un une
difficulté qui était que la proposition
de la Commission visait initialement de
manière indifférenciée les médias
et donc ça posait une difficulté puisque
vous savez que dans la construction de
nos droits nationaux anciens et
notamment le nôtre on a une distinction
entre d'une part la presse écrite
d'autre part l'audiovisuel
donc dans l'ensemble peut-être vous dire
que le ministère de la Culture est est
satisfait du compromis qui a été trouvé
hier par la présidence
bien sûr et il y a des améliorations
encore à apporter au texte mais je crois
que c'est ces discussions intenses ont
permis d'apporter des améliorations
importantes et je voudrais attirer
peut-être votre attention sur trois
avancées majeures que nous avons obtenus
durant ces discussions donc premier
avancée majeure les dispositions
concernant la presse écrite puisque dans
la version initiale du texte
il y avait plusieurs dispositions donc
il posait difficultés au secteur de la
presse dans les professionnels
avaient avaient bien identifié
lors des négociations nous avons veillé
à ce que c'est spécificités soient
prises en compte et des avancées ont
déjà été obtenus dans deux domaines donc
la nouvelle version du texte permet de
concilier l'indépendance du toriale avec
le droit de propriété des médias et donc
ça vise à préserver le cadre français
existant qui a fait ses preuves le
principe de la responsabilité en cascade
qui a inscrit dans la loi de 1881
puisque le directeur de la publication
continuera à assumer la responsabilité
pénale de tout ce qui est écrit et
publié dans son journal et deuxième
domaine sur la régulation de la presse
donc c'est un sujet sensible cela a été
dit puisque la presse n'est pas régulée
a priori les éditeurs de presse ont
évidemment contestés qu'une telle
évaluation soit confiée aux régulateur
audiovisuel et donc nous avons obtenu
que les évaluations des opérations de
concentration qui concerne la presse
écrite puisse être confiée à une
autorité indépendante de l'Autorité de
régulation du secteur audiovisuel et
donc ça devrait laisser une certaine
latitude pour recourir notamment à des
organismes d'auto-régulation voilà et
donc sans doute que sur ce point des
améliorations seront encore à venir
deuxième avancée significative sur les
dispositions relatives à la protection
du pluralisme dans l'environnement
numérique donc l'article 17 plusieurs
modifications je crois ont permis de
donner de meilleures garanties aux
médias vis-à-vis des décisions de
modération des plateformes avec
notamment un délai raisonnable
pour un dialogue entre les parties dans
le cas où un contenu pose problème et la
possibilité de recourir à une médiation
donc un organisme extrajudiciaire de
règlement des litiges c'est une
plateforme refuse le statut de média à
un service qui qui aurait souhaité se
déclarer et bien sûr nous
nous avons obtenu d'exclure les services
de médias qui ne sont pas transparents
dans leur financement ou dans leur
actionnariat donc cet article n'est
peut-être pas encore parfait mais donne
l'occasion de compléter le règlement
européen sur les services numériques
donc le DSA
troisième avancée significativement fin
sur l'article 20 qui prévoit des mesures
nationales ayant une répercussion sur
les médias et qui devaient être
proportionnés transparentes et non
discriminatoires donc la rédaction
initiale de cet article constitué une
préoccupation majeure pour le ministère
de la culture et les professionnels
puisque certains acteurs menacent de son
service pour détricoter les
réglementations nationales en faveur de
la diversité culturelle et en
particulier les avancées
issues de la transposition de la
directive SMA relative notamment à la
protection des œuvres européennes des
obligations d'investissement ou encore
de la chronologie des médias voilà donc
nous avons obtenu avec un large soutien
des États membres que le champ de cet
article soit circonscrit en fait aux
mesures ayant un lien direct avec
l'objet du du texte c'est-à-dire qui
peuvent avoir un impact négatif sur
l'indépendance et le plus réalisme des
médias
voilà rapidement peut-être les les
avancées principales qui ont permis aux
autorités françaises de soutenir ce
texte de compromis de la présidence donc
nous espérons bien sûr que ces progrès
soient consolidés au Parlement et nos
priorités rejoignent celles du député
Geoffroy Didier je crois et donc si je
devais peut-être résumer en un mot
mon propos je dirais que le texte permet
des garanties minimales en matière
d'indépendance et de pluralisme des
médias donc c'est un progrès au sein de
l'Union européenne et la France préserve
globalement c'est fondamentaux merci
beaucoup
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président je suis mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs mesdames messieurs je suis
très heureux d'être aujourd'hui parmi
vous pour vous exposer évidemment
des propos d'un praticien des médias
puisque autour de ce côté-là de la table
il y a d'autres régulateur il y a notre
tutelle donc évidemment moi je ne
pourrais porter que des propos portant
sur justement l'aspect pratique des
choses pour un média et en l'occurrence
un média de service public puisque à ma
droite une représentante d'un média
privé avec qui nous travaillons de façon
très étroite et coordonnée évidemment
pourra s'exprimer le premier point
peut-être que je voudrais souligner
c'est que
il y a eu une démarche de la Commission
européenne qui ont la matière nous
paraît très intéressantes puisque ça
fait un peu plus de deux ans et demi que
Thierry Breton avait évoqué devant
Delphine Ernotte la présidente de France
Télévisions qui est aussi président de
l'Union européenne de radio Diffusion
c'est-à-dire l'association qui regroupe
tous les médias publics
européens et ça va au-delà des des
frontières de l'Union européenne un peu
à l'instar de les regards qu'évoquait
recolivier et c'est vrai que il y a eu
dès le dès les premières idées du
commissaire européen cette volonté
justement de partager avec les
praticiens
de quoi nous avions le plus besoin pour
assurer
l'indépendance des médias qu'ils soient
de service public ou de services privés
et je me rappelle encore d'un appel de
Giuseppe au coeur de l'été ça devait
être un huit ou un 9 août ce qui
démontre que la Commission européenne
travaille en permanence qui justement
s'interrogeait sur les différents états
les différents médias de services
publics au sein du er qui avait des
exemples particulièrement probants à
montrer donc cette démarche qui n'a pas
forcément toujours été celle mise en
oeuvre dans dans le passé et évidemment
à saluer et nous avons essayé d'y
contribuer avec autant de de modestie
que de recherche d'efficacité
sur le texte plusieurs points nous nous
paraissent très importants et très
intéressant le premier mais j'irai assez
brièvement Florence l'évoquais c'est
l'article 5 c'est vrai que la notion
d'indépendance des journalistes même si
c'est quelque chose qui est chevillé au
corps qui est dans l'ADN de tous les
journalistes notamment des journalistes
de service public mais pas que
évidemment et bien c'est c'est important
qu'un texte de niveau européen le
rappelle
dans un contexte où on l'a vu
le conflit en Ukraine aujourd'hui a
donné lieu à une propagation d'un nombre
de fake news particulièrement important
mais il n'y a pas que ce conflit qui
génère justement des problèmes de ce
type et donc qui il était pour nous
assez important que y compris à un
niveau symbolique la Commission
européenne l'Union européenne rappelle
cette nécessité qui est extrêmement
importante et puis pour nous il y a
naturellement cette notion de ressources
financières suffisante et stable qui est
une terminologie qui nous va droite au
coeur mais pas pas uniquement pas
uniquement pour France Télévisions pour
l'ensemble de l'audiovisuel public
la représentation nationale le sait
c'est évidemment pour nous
média de service public qui sommes
amenés à prendre des décisions
d'investissement très importantes
d'investir dans un film d'investir dans
une série d'investir dans une nouvelle
émission c'est évidemment très important
pour nous d'avoir un peu de visibilité
sur nos ressources sur nos ressources
financières que ces dernières puissent
être pérennes que ces dernières puissent
être puissent être stables c'est un
sujet qui donne lieu à beaucoup de
débats à l'heure actuelle à beaucoup
d'échanges avec avec notre tutelle mais
c'est un point qui a été évidemment
extrêmement important je m'arrêterai un
peu plus et puis je serai je serai
beaucoup plus bref sur sur la fin mais
sur une problématique qui a été évoquée
notamment par le président Lafont sur
les la visibilité appropriée je crois
que c'est un sujet qui est extrêmement
important et peut-être faut-il bien
l'expliquer
nous sommes dans un univers dans lequel
les télévisions on achète plus que des
télévisions connectées aujourd'hui et
que donc on peut se dire que d'ici à 10
ans il n'y aura plus dans notre pays que
des téléviseurs connectés c'est quelque
chose qui va extrêmement vite comme vous
le savez il y a un petit événement en
France qui aura lieu au mois de juillet
prochain qui pourrait qui sont les Jeux
Olympiques qui pourraient contribuer
fortement à développer cela donc là les
télévisions connectées c'est vraiment
aujourd'hui le système de diffusion de
l'avenir or ce n'est pas une télévision
c'est un écran d'ordinateur et
aujourd'hui beaucoup de ces téléviseurs
connectés c'est extraordinairement
compliqué de trouver les médias
généralistes comme France Télévisions
mais aussi comme TF1 M6 ou d'autres
médias ça réclame parfois de scroller
pendant 6 ou 7 pages avant d'arriver à
les trouver et c'est évident que cet
univers des téléviseurs connectés qui
est aujourd'hui dominé par quelques
fabricants qui sont tous extra-européens
d'un côté et des interfaces qui sont
développées également par des très
grands des très grands groupes sont et
ce qui peut se comprendre par ailleurs
essentiellement mû pour par l'appât du
gain et c'est évident que sur une
télécommande c'est pas très compliqué à
Netflix ou Amazon d'avoir une touche une
touche Netflix ou Amazon c'est
évidemment beaucoup plus compliqué pour
un média traditionnel comme le nôtre
parce que à des prix que que évidemment
nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre et
lorsque quelqu'un est obligé de tourner
numériquement des pages sur son
téléviseur pour arriver à nous trouver
les statistiques des mondes qu'au bout
de deux ou trois pages les gens
abandonnent et donc il y a un véritable
et je pèse mes mots c'est très important
on veut vraiment bien le souligner il y
a un risque énorme
d'invisibilisation des médias
traditionnels et là on l'espèce je ne
parle pas du tout exclusivement pour
France Télévisions c'est également
valable pour pour les autres parties de
l'audiovisuel public c'est aussi valable
pour nos collègues du privé c'est un
point qui est très important alors
évidemment
la réglementation et les différents
textes ont prévu un certain nombre de
normes mises en œuvre qui vont être
proposées par par larcome et on sait que
le collège et de l'arcom et son
président sont extrêmement sensibilisés
à ces sujets mais nous il nous paraît
extrêmement important qu'au niveau
européen
ces problématiques de visibilité
appropriée soit évoquées parce que ce
sont les médias traditionnels qui
risquent de disparaître au profit des
grandes plateformes qui ont évidemment
beaucoup plus de moyens que nous et par
ailleurs en réglant toujours cette
éternel problème qui est de cette la
capacité à pouvoir imposer des
obligations à des opérateurs qui sont
établis en dehors de l'Union Européenne
si ce n'est pas le cas évidemment tout
ce que l'on fait ne servira strictement
à rien tous les fabricants de
téléviseurs sont extra-européens et et
ceux qui développent les interfaces
également
j'irai très vite sur sur
l'article 17 sur les garanties de
procédure qui ont été très bien évoqués
j'aimerais juste un point qui est
quelque chose qui est également
important c'est l'article 23 pour nous
qui porte entre autres sur les mesures
de audience
nous on est un peu frustré du fait que
on a beaucoup de difficultés à avoir des
données d'audience lorsque nous sommes
relayés par des plateformes ou par des
interfaces c'est dommage parce que ça
nous permet pas de mieux connaître nos
téléspectateurs et nous sommes aussi là
pour essayer de leur apporter ce qu'ils
ont envie de voir donc témoignent les
excellents résultats d'audience de
France Télévisions et notamment de
France 2 mais l'impossibilité ou la très
grande difficulté parce que beaucoup de
rétent sur la matière de pouvoir obtenir
des éléments sur nos mesures d'audience
est évidemment quelque chose qui qui
nous pose qui nous pose des de
véritables problèmes et ce que prévoit
l'article 23 dans ce règlement nous
paraît particulièrement intéressant
voilà je merci de m'avoir écouté désolé
d'avoir pris peut-être un peu de temps
merci beaucoup
merci vous venez de m'apprendre que
finalement on avait l'autonomie
stratégique mais on est aussi
l'autonomie médiatique et que on est
peut-être en train de la perdre donc je
vais passer la parole à Madame gros
cheval RAW pour le groupe M6 bonjour
bonjour merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président bonjour mesdames et sénatrice
messieurs les sénateurs nous vous
remercions de avoir invité le groupe M6
en tant que représentant donc d'un média
privé audiovisuel
je vais également essayer d'apporter un
témoignage un peu plus concret comme
Christophe Tardieu l'a fait pour France
Télévisions d'abord en vous rappelant
que nous éditons chez M6 13 chaînes de
télévision nous avons trois raisons
nationaux de radio et également donc RTL
notamment et une plateforme à la demande
qui s'appelle 6play et nous déployons
donc une offre d'information tout à fait
conséquente sur nos différents services
j'en veux notamment pour preuve la
convention qui a récemment été négociée
avec l'arcom pour une nouvelle
autorisation de 10 ans nous avons pris
un engagement de dans nos télévisés par
jour et également d'un volume horaire de
600 heures d'information par an incluant
les JT mais aussi des documentaires et
des magazines d'information que vous
connaissez puisque certains sont des
marques historiques je pense à zone
interdite ou capital et donc tout ça
pour vous dire que nous avons une vraie
volonté également dans les services
privés d'avoir une offre d'information
qui soit indépendante plus réaliste
honnête qui permettent également à la
société de bouger puisque certains de
nos reportages peuvent également mener
ensuite à des évolutions législatives ça
a été le cas sur l'économie circulaire
il me semble encore assez récemment
par ailleurs nous avons donc une
rédaction enfin plusieurs mêmes
rédactions conséquentes de journalistes
il y a 350 journalistes dans le groupe
et
une audience qui est plutôt jeune pour
nos programmes d'informations ce à quoi
nous tenons afin de pouvoir
effectivement permettre aux médias télé
et à la radio de continuer d'avoir une
audience assez large surtout les publics
nous accueillons pour elles ont là le
projet de règlement avec un regard très
favorable puisqu'il le souligne
l'importance de l'information pour les
citoyens pour la démocratie et pour
l'Europe en général
je voudrais rappeler puisque que que les
groupes français à l'heure actuelle et
les services autorisés en particulier
ont des obligations donc qui peuvent
être d'ordre quantitatif et d'offres
publics mais également à certains de
contraintes déontologiques
qui sont très finement surveillés par le
régulateur et là on revient également
sur insatisfait site du système français
que vous avez souligné je crois monsieur
ababonte donc nous avons la loi de 86
nous avons les conventions il y a un
certain nombre de délibération et puis
plus récemment en 2016 le législateur a
introduit donc une volonté
d'indépendance et d'honnêteté de
l'information qui prend la forme de
charte d'anthologique pour tout groupe
audiovisuel qui dispose de journalistes
donc ça c'est une spécificité de
l'audiovisuel pour radio et télévision
et nous avons un comité éthique qui est
constitué de personnalité indépendante
qui doit donc vérifier le respect de
cette charte c'est-à-dire qu'on est déjà
sur un très haut niveau en fait de
sûreté pour les journalistes avec des
personnalités qui sont hors de
l'entreprise et qui peuvent se permettre
de mener des instruire des saisines ou
de s'informer sur la défense du droit de
la presse la défense des journalistes de
façon interne au groupe et en complément
de ce que fait l'arcom quand nous avons
une partie diffusée à la télévision donc
c'est-à-dire que nous avons assisté
instru par l'arcom et puis un système
interne qui est vérifié par ce comité
donc ça fait un certain nombre de pour
ces raisons là de de
de contexte de cadre qui nous permettent
de dire que nous sommes déjà très très
contrôlés et le texte peut apporter des
des avancées en ce qu'il met un peu les
plateformes
un meilleur niveau cependant
il nous semble que on a quand même pris
voilà on va quand même rester sur des
niveaux de contrôle qui sont pas du tout
de la même finesse et ça vous l'avez
souligné de même évidemment que de
nombreux rapports
nous avons des obligations par exemple
notamment en diffusion qui vont
concerner la protection des mineurs qui
sont contre les par l'arcom qui sont
très lisibles pour le public alors que
les plateformes restent dans une
démarche qui est volontaire qui peut
d'ailleurs en fait rejoindre des
objectifs un petit peu plus disons
marketing c'est à dire qu'on sait très
bien que interdire un programme c'est
aussi lui donner de la visibilité ou en
tout cas souligner que il n'est
accessible et un certain public peut
donner l'envie justement à ceux qui n'en
font pas partie d'aller jeter un œil et
et ça c'est quelque chose sur lesquels
ils peuvent jouer alors que nous nous
avons quelque chose un système qui est
beaucoup plus commun et transparent à
toutes les chaînes on a également des
asymétries en matière de publicité
clandestine notamment sur les
plateformes de partage de vidéo et puis
un certain raffinement français qui a
été introduit pour un certain
obligations je pense au quota musicaux
qui aujourd'hui sont très très disparate
par rapport enfin très disons fin par
rapport à ce qu'on va avoir sur tout ce
qui est à la demande donc le texte ne
vient pas du tout sur ses enjeux là
évidemment que ce soit
le degré de contrôle que nous avons en
matière d'information ou le degré de
contrôle que nous avons de façon plus
générale
nous l'accueillons cependant
favorablement je vous l'ai dit et je
vais donc citer les trois articles
Christophe Tardieu est cité qui vous
illustreront que les les chaînes et les
services se retrouvent bien donc dans
des Exposition des signes
je remercie France Télévisions d'avoir
souligné que les chaînes privées ont
leur place au sein des sigles
puisqu'effectivement c'est ce que dit la
directive elle en tout cas elle ne
l'interdit pas elle évoque des contenus
d'intérêt général qui sont définis elle
ne dit pas qu'il s'agit uniquement des
chaînes de service public de public donc
nous comptons sur l'arcome dans le cadre
de la consultation actuelle et également
sur la diligence de tous pour que les
services du Groupe M6 puissent rejoindre
les signes avec des enjeux absolument
structurants Christophe Tardieu a
rappelé sur lesquels je ne reviendrai
pas il y a également la mesure
d'audience qui est très importante
puisque dans cet environnement beaucoup
plus ouvert nous n'avons pas accès aux
audiences et nous pensons qu'il faudrait
des tiers de contrôle pour pouvoir
vraiment avoir dans le cadre de cet
objectif de mesure d'audience des
plateformes quelque chose qui soit
suffisamment solide et partagée afin que
nous puissions faire reposer
nos modèles à la fois pour toucher les
publics également pour obtenir de la de
la ressource commerciale puisque le rôle
des chaînes publics c'est évidemment
cela
voilà écoutez j'aurai un dernier mot sur
le comité on est quand même assez
sensible au fait que effectivement le
banc doit rester très indépendant c'est
le cas de l'arcome et les mesures à
l'heure actuelle de contrôle et les
relations que nous avons avec les
autorités de régulation en France nous
satisfons on n'a pas toujours gain de
cause comme vous le savez mais en tout
cas le fonctionnement nous paraît très
opérant et effectivement les points de
vigilance qui ont été donnés par la
France en la matière et la recommence et
clairga nous paraissent de voir être
absolument suivi voilà
timing parfait je vous remercie de votre
précision et donc on a une heure pour
pour le débat je vous propose qu'on
commence à ouvrir le débat par écouter
nos deux rapporteurs ici présentes qui
vont s'exprimer l'une après l'autre et
je propose à mes collègues de préparer
ou de rentrer sur la liste des questions
potentielles afin que on puisse on
puisse avancer donc je sais pas qui veut
prendre Florence Florence natrix merci
monsieur le Président
merci à vous toutes et tous pour ces
propos introductrices introductifs qui
ont contribué à nous éclairer
est-ce que vous pourriez nous nous
expliquer brièvement dans quelle mesure
vous avez été associés à l'élaboration
de cette proposition et consulter
ensuite on a bien noté que en effet le
progrès
constatés au Conseil hier satisfont un
certain nombre de ce que nous avions
nous-mêmes proposé et nous semble aller
dans le bon sens la vie du service
juridique du secrétariat général du
Conseil a validé le choix d'appréhender
le secteur des médias par le biais de
l'article 114 du tfuea qui concerne
évidemment l'établissement et le
fonctionnement des marchés intérieurs
tout en faisant droit à certaines
réserves que nous avions émises quant à
la validité de l'article 167 du guide
traité il valide également le choix d'un
règlement alors qu'une proposition de
directive destinée à être transposée en
droit interne aurait laissé aux États
membres le choix de la forme et des
moyens de mise en oeuvre donc nous
sommes bien évidemment
préoccupés des adaptations législatives
qu'aurait entraîné le règlement
qu'entraînerait le règlement sur la loi
de 86 et du 29 juillet
1891 certaines craintes ont pu être
levées et on peut aussi s'interroger
vous avez indiquer que ce ce texte
complétait le DSA et le DMA mais quelle
réelle valeur ajoutée est-ce qu'il
apporte au DSA et au DMA par ailleurs
vous avez
évoqué madame Philibert l'évolution sur
les concentrations et le le qui vous
semble aller dans le bon sens vous nous
avez parlé d'un mécanisme
d'autorégulation comment est-ce que vous
envisagez comment est-ce que vous
envisagez sont son organisation
et enfin
[Musique]
un certain nombre de de
volet de ce texte sont formulés sous la
forme de recommandations et non de
disposition législatives et donc
l'application le suivi de ses
recommandations
selon vous serait-elle confié à des
autorités nationales mais aussi
au Comité européen qui les réunit en
réseau je vous remercie
bonjour à toutes et à tous
je me réjouis
de l'analyse et de la présentation qui a
été faite et je salue notre collègue à
distance je sais pas si nous entend
encore Geoffroy Didier
parce que son analyse en réalité alors
qu'on n'a pas eu d'échange c'est la
première fois qu'on a un échange sur ce
projet de texte conforte complètement
notre analyse et la proposition de
résolution européenne portant à vie
motivé sur la conformité du principe du
subsidiarité que nous avions faites en
réalité les points de vigilance
correspond vraiment à ce que nous avions
soulevé tout comme la directrice
les points qui ont été traités hier en
négociation correspondent également aux
inquiétudes que nous avions tenu à
partager avec vous je pense à la
régulation de la ça a été évoqué par
Olivier Mestre donc une solution semble
avoir été trouvée pour permettre
finalement à une nouvelle autorité vous
avez peut-être nous préciser quelle
forme ça pourrait prendre de s'occuper
de la question de la régulation de de la
presse l'arcane n'ayant pas à ce titre
compétences sur le sujet vous l'aviez
déjà dit nous l'avions fait remarquer
également lors de la table ronde sur la
presse comment ça va s'articuler au sein
du nouveau comité j'aimerais bien voir
un petit peu plus de de précision
vous avez les uns et les autres aussi
rappeler le risque qu'il y avait
d'écraser en quelque sorte les avancées
de la directive SMA en matière de
soutien à la création le respect de la
chronologie des médias vous semble vous
sembler madame la direction sur sur ce
point on voulait vraiment en avoir la la
confirmation et les acteurs du secteur
se sont inquiétés auprès de auprès de
nous les dispositions concernant la
presse écrite en matière de du rôle de
en matière d'indépendance éditoriale
sans balai dans le bon sens même
directrice vous l'avez souligné dans
votre propos en premier point au rang
des avancées marquante de vos
négociations hier
plus largement moi j'ai envie de vous
poser la question
d'ailleurs Geoffroy Didier la comment
dirais exposé au démarrage de son propos
c'est qu'on est dans une séquence on a
énormément de textes européens beaucoup
de projets de règlement aux risques
d'une lisibilité pour le citoyen de
comment tout ça va s'articuler tout ça
comment tout ça va se mettre en
application et en œuvre y compris pour
les acteurs eux-mêmes donc moi
j'aimerais bien comprendre alors que
nous sommes en train de travailler sur
l'application dans notre droit français
du DMA et DSA comment concrètement ce
projet de régulation des médias va
s'articuler avec le le DSA le la
directive
SMA et la directive aussi Capsa 2 dont
on n'a pas reparlé si vous pouviez nous
éclairer sur sur ce sujet et puis moi je
m'interroge un insta de ce café le
président de la font qui n'est plus là
c'est est-ce que on sait vraiment
préoccupé
dans ce texte si on veut asseoir le
pluralisme et l'indépendance de nos
médias faut d'abord se préoccuper de
leur viabilité dans leur survie dans le
temps face à ces mastodontes que sont
les les gafams désormais qui domine très
largement le marché et dont nos médias
dépendent le plus souvent comme
intermédiateur quasi obligatoire
aujourd'hui sans perception vraiment
d'une réelle valeur ajoutée de tout ce
qui est produit sur ces plateformes
hormis la directive et ses mains faut
bien le dire c'est une avancée réelle à
laquelle la France a beaucoup
travaillé mais c'est en préoccupé ou ne
doit pas se préoccuper aussi à travers
ce texte
de des modèles économiques et financier
qui vont permettre de garantir l'avenir
des audiovisuels publics européens qui
pour lutter contre la désinformation la
manipulation des opinions voir des
scrutins publics lors de des élections
voilà moi je Christophe Tardieu a évoqué
l'article 5 qui parle des ressources
financières
les ressources financières suffisantes
et stables c'est en effet assez vague
j'ajouterais d'ailleurs même pérenne
parce que STAPS c'est ce qui ne bouge
pas mais c'est un induit pas une notion
temporelle
voilà je disais que la la comment
dirais-je la présidente
avait insisté sur aussi l'indépendance
du financement de ces audiovisuels
publics pour laquelle réponse le texte
peut-il apporter ou comment peut
pourrait-il être complété dans le cadre
de la poursuite du du dialogue pour moi
c'est un véritable sujet est-ce qu'il
n'y aurait pas moyen non plus
d'articuler ça avec le plan d'action
2030 la boussole numérique pour mettre
des moyens dédiés à ces entreprises
particulières du secteur de
l'audiovisuel public comme privé se
préoccuper de leurs ressources c'est un
enjeu stratégique
très important la survie de nos médias
pour la survie de nos démocraties et de
nos modèles politiques à travers le
monde
peut-être je vous laisse vous organiser
pour répondre à nos deux rapporteurs et
puis après on ouvre le débat avec nos
collègues qui qui commencent à poser des
questions donc je sais pas mon prise de
parole d'une à deux minutes les uns et
les autres comme vous voulez
voir la presse
je vais essayer d'aborder la question de
la relation oui oui
donc je vais essayer d'aborder la
question de la relation entre la loi sur
la liberté des médias les digitales
la
directive sur les services mais il y a
audiovisuel et aussi la directive sat
câble 2
alors pour donc commençons avec la plus
facile à services la directive sur les
services médias audiovisuels donc Madame
Fulbert avait dit qu'il avait un crainte
au début
que l'article 20 de cette directive de
la Loi sur les services
sur la liberté des médias puissent
remettre en jeu les obligations
d'investissement
les quotas les obligations des
financements de la directive service
media audiovisuel sincèrement je n'ai
jamais partagé cette crainte mais non
les textes a été a été aménagé afin de
comment dire de de éliminer toutes
sortes de des malentendus donc la Loi
sur les services médias et de visuel est
une loi qui vise qui contribue au
perfectionnement relâchement du marché
intérieur dans les secteurs il y a y
inclut l'audiovisuel et qui vise à
protéger la liberté des médias les
pluralismes l'indépendance et l'itoriale
n'a rien à voir avec les quotas avec les
mesures de soutien de l'audiovisuel donc
les principes les la relation entre les
deux textes donc entre la proportion
d'argument et la diététique et devrait
être réglé dans progrès par les
principes l'ex spécialiste service média
audiovisuel des regards à la loi
générale qui est la loi sur la sur les
sur la liberté des médias c'est là étant
dit dans les derniers textes dans les
textes qui a été voté hier au Conseil on
a clarifié que l'article 20 de la loi
sur la liberté des médias s'appliquent
seulement aux mesures qui puissent
affecter les pluralismes des médias et
elle a l'indépendance donc papa on
mesure qui relève de la protection de la
diversité culturelle et du soutien de de
des entreprises audiovisuelles
européennes ça c'est la première chose
pour l'aider ça
et pour l'idée ça donc l'idée ça il
s'applique donc c'est une forme de
régulation des plateformes et de la
modélation des contenus qui est assez
innovative et s'applique donc au centre
du DSA c'est il y a identification des
risques systémiques par exemple des
larges campagnes et des informations
qui qui peuvent par exemple déstabiliser
complètement des élections
et
des mesures à mettre en place pour
contenir ces risques pour mitigés les
mitigé les risques
ici dans l'article 17 de la directive de
la du Règlement sur la liberté des
médias
il y a un régime des faveurs pour les
entreprises des médias quand c'est là
sont confrontés à des restrictions
qui découle de l'application des
conditions d'utilisation des grandes
plateformes donc on ne parle pas des
contenus illégaux on parle des contenus
qui sont selon la logique des
plateformes en déciderables comme par
exemple
la nudité comme
par exemple des contenus qui sont
considérés des positions qui sont
considérées trop extrêmement
illégal et là on a donc établi un
système qui est assez complexe et qui se
base sur une déclaration qui doit être
faite par une entreprise des médias
pendant un fournisseur de services des
médias a déclaration qui dans les cas
échéant peut être validé aussi par la
régulateur la dégradation doit être
faite à la plateforme
et une fois que la plateforme reçoit la
déclaration avant de
limiter ces services des intermédiation
vis-à-vis de l'entreprise des médias
doit informer entreprise des médias et
doit justifier la décision des
restreindre les services
d'intermédiation concernant certains
types de contenus et après il y a aussi
un mécanisme qui vise à la résolution à
l'amiable des conflits éventuels entre
une entre les plateformes et les les
services des médias chose qui est très
importante c'est que le nouveau article
17 dans la loi sur les règlements sur la
liberté des médias ne porte pas donc
n'en faites pas et sans préjudice pour
les mesures des modération
identification des risques systémiques
et des modérations des des séries qui
sont prévus par les
je ne sais pas si j'étais clair je fais
mon mon possible
[Musique]
pour les métiers ça cab bon la la les
chevauchement est vraiment il n'y a pas
les chevaux il n'y a pas de
superpositions y a-t-il cette câble est
une directive un peu modeste qui est
celle la proposition des règlements de
la commission au début était beaucoup
plus ambitieuse donc la mission de la
Commission a été modérée pendant la
procédure législative qui devrait
faciliter à la distribution donc la les
transmissions des services médias
audiovisuels à l'intérieur de l'Union
européenne mais sincèrement je ne vois
pas beaucoup de de chevauchement ou des
conflits possibles entre la loi sur la
liberté des médias la directrice à câble
et aussi la directive sur la protection
de droit d'auteur dans les marchés
digitales merci
oui ou merci beaucoup donc dans le
désordre peut-être pour commencer sur la
question de la presse et répondre à la
question de Catherine Morin de saillie
donc je vous confirme notre analyse du
sexe pour nous on est complètement
rassuré sur la question de
l'indépendance éditoriale et la
préservation de nos acquis de la loi de
1881 sur ce point sur la question de la
régulation peut-être des concentrations
donc
nous avons soutenu que le champ de
compétences de l'arcom ne devait pas
être étendu à la presse sous l'effet de
ce règlement européen donc on a défendu
d'abord l'exclusion de du secteur de la
presse de ces articles 21 22 et comme on
était quand même relativement
minoritaire dans cette position
on a essayé de de défendre l'exclusion
des compétences du bord sur ces articles
et ses demandes non pas prospéré donc
nous avons obtenu deux choses
que l'évaluation
prévu par cet article puisse être confié
à plusieurs autorités et donc ce qui
permettrait que les opérations de
concentration presse soit confiées à un
autre organe que l'arcom en réalité mais
c'est un organe qui reste à créer c'est
qui reste à imaginer un organe
d'auto-régulation par exemple qui
viendrait donner son avis donc c'est pas
quelque chose qui existe dans le droit
national à l'heure actuelle et des
travaux d'adaptation de ces dispositions
dans le droit national seront seront
sans doute nécessaire donc voilà et
ensuite les discussions se poursuivent
vous savez qu'on a aussi proposé son
succès à ce stade que la le la
composition du bord soit adaptée dans la
même logique avec un sous-groupe
spécialisé d'experts du secteur de de la
presse pour pour donner des avis sur les
opérations de concentration de la presse
qui reste des bien donc voilà donc tout
ça est encore en cours de travail et de
réflexion on n'a pas à ce stade de
mécanisme tout à fait déterminé mais les
réflexions se poursuivent
sur l'article 20 et la préservation de
de
nos acquis en matière de diversité
culturelle je pense que sur ce point le
le texte a vraiment évolué et la
rédaction vise vraiment à nous rassurer
peut-être qu'il faut
préciser l'articulation de cet article
également avec le régime du droit des
aides d'État pour éviter aussi des
doubles contrôles
inutiles mais là dessus on est on est
également rassuré
peut-être pour répondre aux questions
sur l'article 5 et les médias
publics et pour assurer au passage mon
camarade Christophe Tardieu donc dans le
texte il est fait référence au protocole
d'Amsterdam vous savez que c'est à
chaque État que revient le soin de
définir et d'organiser librement les
missions de son service public
audiovisuel et son financement et la
nouvelle rédaction permet d'établir donc
des principes minimaux qui doivent être
par l'ensemble des États et comme je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure aussi ça permet
de préserver les acquis et la diversité
des modèles nationaux et peut-être sur
la question des ressources financières
pérenne et stables
vous savez que nos modalités de
financement reposent sur deux principes
cardinaux qui sont
être compatibles avec la préservation de
l'indépendance du secteur et permettre à
celui-ci de disposer d'un financement
pérenne et donc évidemment indispensable
à la à la visibilité de la programmation
des entreprises
donc peut-être pour vous rassurer c'est
une exigence qui a été rappelée par le
Conseil constitutionnel dans sa décision
de août 2022 le législateur financier
accorde à l'audiovisuel public en
financement suffisant pour qu'il
accomplisse l'émission qui lui sont
confiées donc là dessus sur la pérennité
et la stabilité je crois que le modèle
français est
préserver
sur la question du soutien au modèle
économique et à l'articulation avec
France 2030
c'est déjà le cas puisque certaines des
entreprises alors de l'audiovisuel
public pour l'instant mais mais c'est
c'est dispositifs sont ouverts à tout le
champ et tout le chant des industries
culturelles donc que ce soit les médias
audiovisuels la presse et l'ensemble des
industries culturelles donc les
dispositifs de France 2030 sont ouverts
et s'applique ent à tous à partir du
moment où on remplit des des conditions
d'innovation dans des technologies et
donc c'est ces dispositifs contribuent
au-delà de toute notre corpus de soutien
d'aide direct indirect et de la
réglementation qui est en constante
évolution permet de contribuer au
soutien de ces modèles c'est bien sûr
aussi le cas pour la presse écrite
peut-être pour compléter ce que vous
avez dit Monsieur abondante sur
l'articulation de l'article 17 avec le
DSA on partage complètement le point
puisque notre analyse et que
le DSA organise l'information et les
possibilités de recours suite à la
suppression d'un contenu mais ne
prévoyez pas de dispositions spécifiques
pour la modération des contenus des
médias et ce projet de règlement qui
complète le DSA il organise le dialogue
en réalité entre les plateformes et les
médias a priori et donc pour les les
contenus qui qui font l'objet d'une
mesure de modération avant que celle-ci
ne soit mise en oeuvre il y a un
processus de dialogue
donc qui permet de d'éviter de protéger
les médias contre des décisions qui
pourraient être
prises
unilatéralement par ses principaux
réseaux sociaux par exemple sur la base
de de leurs conditions générales donc
pour nous
vis-à-vis des médias c'est c'est un
progrès par rapport par rapport à
l'existant
voilà je crois à peu près avoir fait le
tour des questions merci vous ajoutez
quelque chose en quelques secondes
été associé à laboration de ce texte
consultation publique et lancée par la
Commission européenne les regards comme
je vous l'ai dit dans mon propre
activement 2 pour dire que la regarde se
réunit la semaine prochaine à Naples et
adoptera sûrement une expression
publique cette occasion sur le dernier
état du texte tel qu'il ressort de
l'adoption hier par le par le corps et
père je pense que les points de
vigilance que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
notamment la question de l'indépendance
du board seront sûrement à nouveau la
pédagogie c'est la répétition jamais
inutile sur l'articulation avec le SMMA
je crois que le directeur a bien précisé
les choses un seul fait que la loi
spéciale des roches à la loi générale
grands principes du droit c'est un point
central parce que Madame Morin de Sailly
très bien dit c'est un apport majeur
singulièrement en France ou en un modèle
de financement de la création qui fait
que l'apport de la contribution des
plateformes et centrale probablement de
l'ordre en rythme manuel un peu plus de
250 millions d'euros donc c'est pas
neutre sur la multiplication des tailles
je partage tout à fait ce que vous
disiez à un moment de saillie il y aura
un certain nombre un effort de pédagogie
très important à faire et en particulier
sur le règlement européen sur les
services numériques le fameux DSA je
sais votre attachement la langue
française donc j'utilise l'expression
française
c'est un texte qui est très différent de
la régulation audiovisuelle en réalité
monsieur ababante elle a dit c'est une
régulation à caractère systémique c'est
pas une régulation de contrôle de
contenu individuel les uns après les
autres comme on peut encore l'opérer
dans le champ dans le champ du visuel et
ça il faudra bien l'expliquer à nos
concitoyens sur ce point l'un des
intérêts de la face c'est de préciser
par rapport au règlement européen sur
les services numériques la façon dont
les contenus
issus de médias sont traités parce que
le texte du DSA peut amener des
plateformes à éliminer des contenus pour
répondre aux risques auquel leur
plateforme sont encourues et donc il
peut y avoir le risque effectivement
d'éliminer des contenus potentiellement
problématiques en provenance de médias
mais ces contenus doivent faire l'objet
d'un traitement très précautionneux
puisqu'ils viennent de titres et de
médias qui contribuent à la liberté
d'informations ce point de vue là
l'article 17 de la fois est un point
d'attention très important sur les SIG
qui ont été évoqués à plusieurs reprises
c'est un dossier central pour le
régulateur je les redis ici publiquement
sur lequel on est bien évident
pleinement engagé pour répondre aux
préoccupations des acteurs publics et
privés les acteurs publics sont protégés
par la loi elle-même qui a transposé la
directive service médiocre du visuel
pour les acteurs privés l'extension de
la
est actuellement on fait actuellement
l'objet d'une consultation publique de
la part de l'arcom et c'est un sujet sur
lequel on se statuera dans le courant de
cette année même mais c'est vrai qu'un
renforcement sur ce point au sein de la
foi comme l'a évoqué Christophe Tardieu
de manquerait pas d'intérêt
vis-à-vis de constructeurs qui sont des
constructeurs extra-européens pour la
plupart
donc je ne peux que souligner ce point
et enfin je partage tout à fait
l'observation de Madame Morin de saillie
sur l'interrogation des modèles
économiques des médias on sait combien
la presse écrite a été percutée ces
dernières années par l'évolution de son
modèle
même si les stratégies numériques de la
presse écrite maintenant pour certains
titres ont marqué de vrais progrès mais
cette interrogation est posée le média
radio est aujourd'hui interrogé
directement sur l'évolution de ses
ressources avec un marché publicitaire
qui connaît une tendance
peut favorable il en est de même de la
télévision donc il faut qu'on soit très
attentif dans les années qui viennent à
ce sujet ça vaut pour les médias publics
ça vaut aussi beaucoup pour les médias
privés dont on ne parle jamais assez et
qui contribue activement eux aussi au
pluralisme et au financement de la
production et la création pardon
monsieur le Président
on est toujours dans les temps alors on
a trois questions pour l'instant je vais
commencer par Bernard fialer et Pierre
Laurence prépare
merci monsieur le Président moi
j'aimerais simplement venir et insister
un peu et avoir un peu plus d'éclairage
on a parlé donc nous avait rassuré sur
la liberté l'indépendance des médias la
liberté des journalistes mais qui dit
liberté dit aussi responsabilité alors
M6 nous rassure par son comité d'éthique
mais qui est propre à la société madame
Philibert vous nous parlez
la responsabilité en cascade de
l'article de de la loi 80 mais qui est
française qu'est-ce qu'on a sur la
déontologie
des des journalistes au niveau 20 quelle
garantie peut-on avoir dans ce domaine
là
pierre
oui merci
d'abord je voudrais remercier pour la
tenue de cette table ronde parce que on
prend encore mieux conscience que jusque
là de l'importance et des enjeux de
ce règlement donc je pense que la terre
de mobilisation politique ou sens
profond du terme on sent l'importance de
de ce texte parce que avant d'être un
objet de marché c'est d'avoir un objet
de culture
donc c'est vraiment les questions du
pluralisme de la démocratie de la
diversité de la culture ces enjeux-là
fondamentaux qui sont qui sont en jeu
donc il y a beaucoup de points de
vigilance bon je veux pas pour faire
juste une question courte je voudrais
insister sur et comprendre un peu mieux
sur une question très concrète qui a été
évoquée par Monsieur Tardieu c'est cette
histoire des télécommandes
qui me paraît essentiel parce que bon
pour prendre un exemple qui est
peut-être pas comparable mais personne
n'a jamais acheté 90 % des gens en
France n'ont jamais acheté un logiciel
ils sont achetés un ordinateur qui
imposait des logiciels et puis pour les
plus informés au bout d'un moment ils se
rendent compte qu'il peut y avoir un
problème avec ça mais
l'envahissement du marché s'est fait par
le matériel
donc là si on a des télécommandes qui
flèche le service ou qu'il impose
le problème si je puis dire va être vite
réglé si on n'impose pas d'énormes donc
moi ma question puisque on n'a pas
entendu le représentant la représentante
du Ministère et le représentant de la
Commission européenne sur cette question
c'est quel est votre opposition sur
cette question êtes-vous pour une norme
européenne
de télécommande qui garantissent la
neutralité d'accès à l'ensemble des
services et j'ai une question
complémentaire à Monsieur abamonde sur
ce sujet qui peut concerner la direction
de Monsieur breton à la Commission
européenne
ce problème au delà de la question de la
norme et de la télécommande mais elle
doit sur un autre problème c'est notre
dépendance industrielle totale
on la matière
comme on est dans un effacement entre le
matériel et les services cette
dépendance industrielle va poser des
problèmes croissants à l'on pose déjà
beaucoup donc est-ce que la direction
de Monsieur breton à la Commission
européenne qui maintenant a le mérite de
porter le débat sur la politique
industrielle européenne est-ce qu'on
envisage de de sortir de cette situation
où tous les producteurs de matériel
audiovisuel
sont extra-européens et peuvent être
amenés par des accords avec les
plateformes à imposer en vérité toutes
les normes aux matières du service
merci de garder bien vos réponses parce
qu'on est des troisième
question par André Richard oui merci
président ce sera très court
en matière de protection de la diversité
culturelle
j'ai bien compris que vous êtes un peu
rassuré les uns et les autres
moi je voudrais particulièrement
insister sur
les langues et culture régionales est-ce
que à cet égard vous avez le même degré
d'assurance de garantie
je suis bien obligé de dire qu'à l'heure
actuelle en qualité d'alsacien je me
retrouve pas toujours et le moins loin
sans faute dans
la préservation des langues et culture
régionales dans l'audiovisuel dans le
public ça va à peu près monsieur Tardieu
et encore on peut faire des efforts mais
il faudrait au moins conserver ça et
quand vous entend parler d'absence de
visibilité à l'avenir
du secteur public
je m'inquiète sur effectivement
la pérennité de nos langues et culture
régionale et en sens inverse vraiment
pour faire très court est-ce que il y a
eu une une
comment dire une attention accrue ou
portée à l'utilisation des langues des
langues
dans dans ce règlement vous savez que
naturellement
il suffit de changer une la langue la
maîtrise de la langue pour
qu'effectivement on inclut on exclut
toute une catégorie
de population susceptibles d'être
intéressés dans certains membres je vise
pas la France là bien dans un certain
nombre de pays
on utilise allègrement cette cette
solution là pour pour exclure bien
est-ce que dans ce règlement on a pris
en compte
la question de la maîtrise de la langue
par les populations concernées et
naturellement
sont son aboutissant
l'utilisation d'une langue par un média
je vous remercie
bien comme tout à l'heure vous organisez
pour les réponses mais je pense qu'il y
a quelques répondeurs
identifiés
je vais commencer peut-être
sur la question sur la déontologie
des journalistes sous votre contrôle
ce n'est pas le cœur de de du texte de
du règlement qui est sur la table même
s'il y a des choses sur la prévention
des conflits d'intérêts je crois à
l'article 6 et peut-être des garde-fous
vous savez dans le dans le dans la
recommandation de la Commission
européenne qui est associée aux
règlements
et ensuite en droit national il y a
évidemment tous les acquis de la loi de
la loi Bloch notamment sur les comités
relatifs à l'honnêteté l'indépendance et
au pluralisme de l'information dans les
programmes sur les langues régionales
mais peut-être que je vous laisserai
monsieur à ma montée complétée je crois
qu'il y a eu un des ajouts considérant 6
du texte suite à une demande de nos de
la délégation sloven et enfin sur les
les services d'intérêt général mais
peut-être que
complètera
donc
l'article 7 bis de la directive SMA
offrait
un premier outil aux États membres pour
favoriser donc
la faculté d'adopter des dispositions
sur la visibilité appropriée des
contenus d'intérêt général donc la
France c'est en paraître cette faculté
dans la loi du visuel c'est une avancée
importante qui permettra de garantir la
visibilité appropriée
des médias dans notre système national
et l'arcom doit à la fois définir les
modalités d'application précise et le
champ
pour aller plus loin c'est une question
dont nous avons discuté avec la
Commission européenne et
dans les travaux qui ont été menés ces
derniers mois
nous avons considéré donc cette
proposition avec attention
mais il faut aussi avoir en tête la
complexité de la mise en oeuvre et la
faible appétence des autres États
membres déjà de se saisir de cette
première faculté donc il ne faudrait pas
que une modification de ses acquis
viennent affaiblir finalement la
position plus ambitieuse qui a été la
nôtre quand ces dispositions ont été
adoptées voilà dans le dans la directive
SMA
pour répondre à votre question donc
l'écran de télévision devient en réalité
de plus en plus un simple magasin
d'applications comme votre téléphone
portable 85 % des postes de télévision
maintenant sont connectés à Internet si
vous achetez un téléviseur ça a été très
bien dit par Christophe Part-Dieu et le
parc se renouvelle assez vite en France
en moyenne 6 septembre
avant que les Français ne changent de
téléviseur donc ça ça va quand même
assez vite les téléviseurs qu'on achète
vous êtes sur un magasin d'applications
quand vous allumez votre télévision vous
avez plus la une la 2 la 3 et 4 et vous
avez des applications qui apparaissent
et votre télécommande d'ailleurs de plus
en plus c'est un simple pointeur qui
vous permet de naviguer sur votre écran
de télévision il y a plus souvent plus
du tout de numéro
30% des Français sont déjà équipés de
dispositifs du type Apple TV ou les clés
chromecast qui sont des connexions
directement Internet et vous rentrez
dans un univers d'accès au contenu qui
sont un magasin d'applications vraiment
exactement comme un smartphone donc si
on y prend pas Garande mais c'est déjà
très largement le cas aujourd'hui
puisque même quand vous avez accès à la
télévision par votre fournisseur d'accès
Orange
SFR Free ou Bouygues Telecom quand vous
allumez votre portail votre Box vous
arrivez sur le portail Orange et vous
avez des bandeaux qui apparaissent avec
des offres qui sont souvent des offres
payantes Netflix Amazon Disney plus
Canal+
mais vous avez plus accès spontanément
aux chaînes de télévision et Christophe
Tardieu elle a assez bien dit il faut
naviguer chercher un peu vous arrivez au
bout du compte à le trouver mais c'est
plus l'expérience qu'on avait autrefois
en regardant la télévision en famille
sur son canapé on choisissait la une la
deux la trois
donc si on n'y prend pas garde nos
opérateurs de télévision nationaux sont
purement et simplement évincés dans
accès spontané à leur contenu d'où
l'importance de la mesure qui est dans
la directivation à transposer dans le
droit français et que nous sommes en
train de mettre en application des
services d'intérêt général donc c'est un
texte qui permet d'imposer aux
interfaces par lesquelles on peut
accéder au contenu sur nos écrans
d'imposer l'exposition privilégiée de
services dit d'intérêt généraux et la
loi donc française qui transpositive dit
que le service public donc France
Télévisions France médiumonde Arte sont
qualifiés automatiquement de service
d'intérêt généraux donc auront vocation
à être exposées de façon privilégiée et
que cette liste peut ensuite être
étendue à d'autres acteurs la loi fixe
en deux familles de critères la
contribution au pluralisme et la
contribution à la diversité culturelle
donc nous avons déjà publié une première
délibération avant le 15 mars de cette
année qui fixe la liste de tous les
acteurs qui seront soumis à l'obligation
d'exposer les services d'intérêt général
donc la liste de toutes les interfaces
dont les fournisseurs d'accès bien
évidemment les univers que j'ai évoqués
tout à l'heure donc qui sont obligés de
mettre en oeuvre les services d'intérêt
généraux
deuxièmement on a lancé il y a 8 jours
maintenant donc une consultation de tous
les acteurs comme nous impose la loi de
le faire pour leur demander ceux qui
souhaitent être service d'intérêt ou
même si on connaît un petit peu la
réponse pour savoir avec quel modalité
il souhaite être exposé est-ce que c'est
les chaînes telles qu'on les connaît
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il faut prendre en
compte leur service de Replay ou est-ce
qu'il faut prendre en compte les
plateformes puisque toutes les opertes
de télévision aujourd'hui maintenant
sont organisées en plateforme on se
télévisions c'est France point TV
TF1 c'est MyTF1 6play pour pour M6 et
ainsi de suite donc cette consultation
va se dérouler jusqu'au 14 juillet de
cette année on en fera la synthèse et on
arrêtera notre dispositif de SIG à
l'automne l'objectif étant que le
dispositif soit soit en vigueur au tout
début de l'année 2024 mais je rejoins
tout à fait ce que dit Florence Philbert
ce qui a dit Christophe Tardieu tout à
l'heure
c'est vrai que dans la mesure où on
s'adresse
aussi à des constructeurs qui sont des
constructeurs extra-européens avoir une
règle européenne peut-être plus plus
robuste à l'avenir que les sols
dispositions que je viens d'évoquer ne
serait probablement pas inutile et vous
connaissez mon sens de lepisme
merci sur le sujet en question c'est
qu'on est finalement toujours dans la
réaction quoi et beaucoup de mal à
anticiper sur ces sujets tellement ça va
vite
il y avait encore des questions qui me
suivent le directeur
merci
une question sur la sur la la
justification de leur proposition donc
nous on doit toujours justifier on ne
peut pas légiférer
des façons
en anglais de façon arbitraire il faut
toujours avoir une base solidité et la
seule base juridique qu'on avait dans
ces cas-là qui requiert la majorité
qualifiée et l'article 114 on a fait des
efforts
énormes
pour pouvoir justifier la proposition
devant les les
comités qui s'occupent de l'évaluation
de l'impact avec les cellules juridiques
du Conseil avec avec les États membres
il y a toute une série de questions
comme par exemple la maîtrise des
langues par les populations concernées
qui ne relève
pas du tout des compétences de la
Commission européenne à Bruxelles sont
des poux des questions vraiment des
subsidialités ce sont des questions que
les États membres normalement veulent
continuer à réguler au niveau national
on est pas vraiment bien placé pour les
faire
débourser et ça c'est important parce
que qu'est-ce qu'on vise dans ces
règlements on vise des mesures qui
peuvent créer des qui peuvent avoir une
incidence négative potentielle sous les
fonctionnements du marché intérieur donc
on vise des mesures importantes comme
par exemple
des exemples pour les considérant 38 des
règles visant à limiter la propriété des
entreprises des médias par d'autres
entreprises actives dans les secteurs
des médias ou dans d'autres secteurs non
liés par les médias ça c'était des cas
en Italie avec Vivendi qui a essayé de
racheter une participation des contrôles
de médiaset et qui a été bloqué par une
loi Haddock qui était après considéré
comme discriminatoire et pas légitime
par la Cour de justice ça sont les
choses qu'ils ont visé visé par les
règlements ou par exemple un système de
des licences qui permet l'exercice de la
profession de fournisseurs des médias
qui soit discriminateurs
ça sont les choses et aussi des
concentrations qui ont un impact réel
sous les marchés intérieurs
tous les restes ne relèvent pas ne
devrait pas relever du champ
d'application du règlement pour des
raisons que j'expliquais avant de
subsidiarité la dernière chose pour la
déontologie des journalistes on dit pas
grand chose ici dans les règlements ce
que les règlements vise à rendre les
journalistes plus indépendants plus
facile aussi et la
profession des journalistes
la question de la déontologie et
adressée dans la stratégie européenne
sous la lutte à la désinformation et
notamment notamment par les codes des
bonnes pratiques
qui est les seuls existants au monde
pour contraster la désinformation en
ligne et là il y a de des mesures qui
visent à vérifier la
la qualité des sources la qualité des
sources non c'est par exemple en journal
respectent des règles d'iontologiques de
la prévention journalistique minimum ça
c'est très très important pour permettre
à l'usager de comprendre si la source
dans certains types d'informations et on
trouve un livre effiable ou non comme ça
c'est ça ma réponse merci
juste parce que pour Monsieur et Madame
disait que la Slovénie aurait rajouté
quelque chose concernant les langues et
culture régionales vous pouvez nous en
dire un mot et puis je précise juste que
j'ai bien compris votre réponse sur
l'utilisation de la langue qui pour vous
ressort de la compétence des États pour
moi je suis plutôt en désaccord parce
que quand on voit pour moi ici il s'agit
une question d'état de droit là l'État
de droit
un vecteur audiovisuel qui utilise une
langue pour inclure ou exclure une
partie de sa population c'est c'est je
trouve que l'Union européenne devrait
s'en emparer
vous l'ajouter quelque chose en réponse
pas spécifiquement
pendant que vous cherchez peut-être il y
a Karine de saïdes peut-être une
remarque qu'on pourra tout de même
déplorer que sur le la langue utilisée
pour le communiqué de presse du Conseil
hier sur l'accord de négociation une a
été exclusivement publiée qu'en anglais
voilà
bon voilà je le dis parce que je pense
que l'Europe en effet doit être une
excellente remarque qu'on se fait très
souvent il faut rappeler que le français
et l'angle aussi de l'Union et beaucoup
beaucoup des travaux et beaucoup des
textes qui sont souvent des textes
complets sont produits en langue
anglaise souscrit tout à fait à votre
observation madame c'est latrice voilà
Monsieur le Directeur si vous pouvez
remonter cette remarque
on fait confiance
je l'ai fait
l'ajoute c'est une ajoute donc c'est
dans les conséquences 6 et où on fait
référence à l'article 22 de la de la
Charte des droits fondamentaux qui
demandent donc l'Union européenne le
respect des
de la diversité culturelle
linguistique et religieuse mais bien sûr
ça c'est une c'est dans un conseil dans
un considérant donc c'est une
disposition pour des principes général
mais encore une fois Monsieur les
sénateurs ça serait
terriblement difficile pour la
Commission européenne européenne
justifiée un instrument marchand
antérieur qui essayent de s'émer avec
des questions de
religieuses linguistique et des respects
des diversités culturelles régionales
régionales dans les états
je pense qu'on réagirait au principe de
subsidiarité
j'ai une toute dernière question elle
est très courte elle s'adresse plutôt à
vous monsieur le directeur mais les
autres intervenants peuvent tout à fait
aussi réponds il s'agit de la question
des concentrations qui a évoqué dès
leçons dès le préambule de cette réunion
le président
Lafont est-ce que quand vous élaborez un
tel texte vous réfléchissez vraiment de
manière globale avec une vraie véritable
étude d'impact sur cette question en
effet surveiller les concentrations
c'est aussi vouloir garantir le
pluralisme des médias notamment la
presse écrite mais ça vaut aussi pour la
presse par les médias
audiovisuels mais on sait aussi à
l'heure du tout numérique et de ses
grandes plateformes que parfois il faut
disposer de masse critiques suffisante
pour c'est toujours les histoires du
modèle économique et de la survie de nos
entreprises il faut aussi parfois
disposer d'une masse critique pour
pouvoir continuer donc à travailler à
fournir les contenus et bien sûr à
exister on a l'impression parfois que
l'Europe voilà l'histoire des
concentrations c'est vraiment tabou et
que nos droits de la concurrence
empêche parfois des regroupements utiles
on a tous en tête le rapprochement
d'Alstom et si même ce qui a capoté
c'était pour faire pièce quand même aux
géants canadiens au géants chinois dans
le domaine du ferroviaire là est-ce que
on est on regarde bien en contrebalance
pour bien voir parfois qui est peut-être
des rapprochements utiles voilà c'est ma
question je crois qu'un joignait la
préoccupation du président de la France
je vais faire de mon mieux
les règles sous les concentrations ne
sont pas contenues donc sous l'impact
des concentrations sous les marchés
sur les marchés sur le marché affecté
par la concentration et sous les
possibles justifications d'une
concentration ne sont pas contenues dans
ces règlements-là soit on continue dans
les règlements sur les concentrations
c'est qu'on fait ici c'est de ajouter
une évaluation des l'impact dans
certains types de concentration sous le
pluralisme des médias et sous la liberté
des médias comme je le disais dans mon
intervention donc au début de la réunion
la France a déjà ce type des critères
l'Italie aussi d'autres pays n'ont pas
ces critères donc l'exemple typique ces
villages de Hongrie en Hongrie les
gouvernements
orbanes a créé en conglomérat des médias
qui s'appelle casema
un Hongrie il n'y avait pas donc une
exigence de devoir et examiner la
transaction de l'opération l'impact de
la transaction sous les pluralismes des
médias sous la liberté des médias et
donc la concentration a été adoptée et
bien sûr il n'y avait pas des comités
donc il n'avait pas des comités
européens qui s'arrangent qui pouvait
aussi s'exprimer sur la concentration
donc maintenant on a un conglomération
à des médias en Hongrie qui a
quasimentopole où il y a tous les
budgets de l'État sur la publicité
d'État qui donc il est seul finalement
bénéficiaire du budget d'État sous la
publicité et tout cela est inattaquable
au niveau européen mais il pourra être
examiné au sens du nouveau article 22 je
crois du Règlement sur la liberté des
médias
très bien écoutez je vous remercie
c'était très très intéressant excusez
les collègues qui ont du partir parce
qu'ils étaient races ils étaient
rappelés en séance plénière pour la
plupart parce que nous avons le texte
sur l'industrie verte donc voilà en tout
cas un grand merci et voilà je pense que
nous continuerons ces travaux parce que
ils sont en perpétuel
évolution merci à vous merci